Kalli is in washington d.c she says my
husband refuses to cut up our credit
card because we plan to travel to Europe
at some point soon and he thinks we'll
need it for booking hotels is there a
way to travel internationally and not
use a credit card sure hope so I'm going
to France in three weeks I guess I'm
probably not going to be able to stay in
a hotel there I bet I won't be able to
eat out there maybe I should stay home
that's dumber than crap come on Cali
really I mean that's just dumb
they don't take debit cards in Europe
give me a break
if they take Visa they take Visa if they
take MasterCard they take MasterCard I
mean now this hasn't got anything to do
at some point we try to plan to travel
to Europe well when would that be like
after you get out of credit card debt
because you believe carrying a credit
card in your pocket is good idea that's
just dumb
it's just straight-up them you don't
even have a Europe trip planned
I'm leaving in three weeks for Europe
but I don't have a day I don't have a
credit card
I sure hope Europe still open sure hope
they let me in I got my passport maybe
I'll be ok what do y'all think your
debit card will do everything your
credit card will do and they accept run
you into debt it won't do that so you
better make sure your money in your
account when you go to Europe in order
to pay for the Europe trip which if you
don't have the money to pay for a Europe
trip you probably shouldn't go to Europe
there's a shocking idea I think now we
got the core of your problem didn't we
yeah there it is right there that's
what's really going on with your husband
he's afraid he won't get to make his
Europe trip unless he borrows the money
to do it that's what's really going on
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]